thank you for the introduction
so I'm going to say something about
embedded systems programming in C++ I
have built on very small systems but not
very recently so if I'm making a big
goof kind be kind anyway so I'm going to
tell give my view of what embedded
systems programming is some C++
fundamentals and then I'm going to go
into to sort of case studies what do you
do when you're really pressed for for
speed and and and space and the other
one is what can you actually do if you
can use the whole language and and
that's that's sort of it and the
emphasis is on reliably in liability
maintainability predictability fast
enough and small enough if you want the
world record and speed and something
like that you can do that too but that's
not what I'm talking about here if it's
fast enough it's fast enough and that's
to run for a few years without anybody
touching it that's more interesting in
this context so basically oops this
thing is very touchy so basically the
point about embedded systems is that
it's so many things that there are
people especially people who's not doing
it who thinks it's one thing and think
they know what it is I know at least as
much to know that I don't know what it
is yeah that is there's no one thing for
it to programming a wind turbine and a
coffee machine is not the same there are
certain similarities like you won't get
an operator on-site but things are
different constraints are not the same
hard real-time is very important soft
real-time if you're doing a video
or an amplifier something that gives
sound or music if you lose a frame or
part of a timing measure yeah so what
nobody dies and we can't hear it we
can't see it but with hard real-time if
you're adjusting the wingtips you better
get it right
precisely so these things are different
and that's that that's important it also
makes it really really hard to talk
about you can talk about one specific
thing how do you program the coffee
machine that's not part or how do you
program the rocket motor that is harder
but it is again specific point is from a
point of view of the language we don't
know we don't know what you are
programming and what the constraints are
and oops did it again
so I'm having some technical problem
here
so there's commonalities Oh Pro no
program on present and the computer is
an integral part of a gadget you don't
actually go and buy and program you buy
a gadget that contains one it could
could be a rocket it could be one of
those microcontrollers there and there's
common questions that we always ask can
it be connected if it's connected how
what about security can it fail and how
will you recover I mean if you're there
was that that read distributed system
with wheels and previous it has more
than a hundred processors in it if one
of them crashes you can get rebooted and
take know or unless one of the
specialized ones where you only have one
so it gets house of failure recover is
always an issue concurrency I just heard
about embedded systems running eight
cores and using load balancing for for
power preservation I'd never thought
that I should use a multi-core to save
power but I was in ship and about a
month ago
and they were doing it
and so if there's a human operator the
human interface human machine interface
is really critical think of a plane C or
a modern car and course that's all this
telemetry comes out of it this is fairly
standard questions and again there's
questions from the programming point of
view can we afford priests or dynamic
store heap whatever it is I mean one of
the the rules in many cases is don't
malloc in any form shape shape or form
after the plane takes off that's just
not allowed on the flight and
regulations for instance and should we
worry about runtime performance it may
be that we just have to do a little bit
steadily along the way and there's other
cases where we're really pressed for
time the processor is slow relative to
what we have achieved we don't know this
this this drives me nuts from the point
of view of saying something general I
can't and should we worry about memory
cost usually the answer is yes I mean if
you are on a satellite you have to carry
that stuff into space and get destroyed
by heart radiation so we need all the
memory we can get and we can't afford to
send it you want to build something and
ship a hundred million gadgets well a
little bit of memory and each sensor and
what our embedded systems programmers
it's well it's roughly everybody presume
everybody in this room at least some of
professional programmers they code for a
living they've got an education and in
in computer science or software
development or something and then
there's a lot of Engineers for no
programming training and still write
code some of the best people I know for
writing code I electrical engineers but
I've seen examples of people who I know
everything I'm an engineer that is not a
good attitude to code the code has
changed or as complexities have changed
techniques have changed
and if you think what you learn in a
simply code back in pickle University 20
years ago yeah probably in slight
trouble and so between those two
caricatures we have everybody else and
we tend to have a mixture of the
domain-specific knowledge maybe coffee
machines it may be flight trolls and our
knowledge about code and I find that
most people don't really want to be C++
experts they just want to get their work
done with the least pain and that's very
reasonable and good and I think I
understand that I'm not sure everybody
who into programming languages
understand that one thing that's driving
a lot of what we are doing is complexity
the code component of our systems is
steadily increasing I mean 20 30 years
ago those hardly any code and embedded
gadget today it is a huge component and
of course it's always the last bit to
get finished so we get the blame the
complexity of the code we're writing is
complete is is increasing with the size
of the programs we are writing and also
with the complexity of the tasks that
that that we are trying to achieve and
so our needs change
I can reasonably confidently predict
that our programs will be more
complicated and more complex more
demanding in five years than they are
today we need all the help we can get
and that's my way of approaching the
code is that we are working at the
limits of what we can handle and we need
to to help there and well we need all
the help we can get
so I was reading a survey recently
there's interest surveys about what
people do and this particular one set
the 50% of of embedded code was see 25%
with C++ and 25 was the
now I could also have picked another
review that I read on the same day which
said something completely different so
just to get me an idea about who you are
- to call a little hands up to get a
view you see I'm going to tell you what
they are and then I'm going to call it C
and C++ and all the things I have never
actually built a system in a single
language there's always something else
going on if nothing else in the testing
framework and such so I assume other C++
and not C the C and C++ and other only
so who is doing see and not C++
okay who's doing C++ and not C Wow and
who's doing both
yeah that's me okay so and other only
okay thanks Matt that gives idea it also
gives me an idea that you may know more
than I expected when I wrote this and
well we'll see what happens but but
here's my view of programming languages
there are two lines of development
there's a low line down there that deals
were hardware you want to get every byte
and every cycle done well you go from
assembler to BCPL to C and C++ and then
people notice that dealing with a
machine directly is somewhat tedious in
many cases and you need better
abstractions that are more suitable for
humans for a particular domain so it
starts with Fortran and this john backus
up there that gave the domain-specific
abstractions for linear algebra dense
linear algebra that's Fortran and once
was done everybody wanted one for their
domain so the business people got COBOL
you didn't want any of this cryptic a
equals B plus C stuff that is too
complicated but you got something else
more appropriate for that domain
and in about five to ten years those
depending on how you count call it a few
dozen a few hundred languages and the
communities couldn't talk to each other
because well Fortran even the basic
arithmetic looks different from the
basic and second COBOL and so on and
this is theis new go or come in and olio
Honda but there's only room for one
picture here said Y built in the
application specific concepts into the
language
why don't we instead give people the
ability to build in their own ideas
their own concepts built their own types
or type hierarchy is something like that
that's how we got Simula and I had a
problem when I started at Bell Labs I
wanted to build a distributed system and
I needed something to write the
schedulers process schedulers memory
managers device drivers network drivers
and such so obviously I had to operate
on the low line here and I also needed
to be able to talk about the system
there's this bit here that talk to that
bit there they talk in this particular
way through this communication
infrastructure I needed abstraction so
no language could do both so I built C++
by taking basically ideas from Simula
and putting it into C and and everything
came came from there later
my background started out with small
machines that up there is a small
machine it is a PDP 11 7 C it's
consumption and Dennis Ritchie working
on it I worked on that machine - you
could get 256 K of memory half of it was
read/write the other half was was
read-only so and then I worked on the
LSI Elevens that was smaller the idea of
having a whole megabyte of memory is
sort of Wow lots of memory ok so that my
background and when people tell me they
can't get their program running on a 10
gig machine
scratch my head and wonder how they
could waste that much that that takes
Talent but anyway this is kind of tough
and I like blood I hate bloated code I
like sort of concise code that can also
understand it better than bloated code
and I don't like bugs I have repeatedly
had worked on systems that must in crash
and so that that that's that's how I get
into programming C++ has a machine that
it shares mostly will see that basically
says we map straight to Hardware
hardware is right there if I do a plus I
get the add instruction if I want to
access memory memory is just a sequence
of object sequence of bytes usually and
you can point to it with an address very
simple and if you want to combine
something if you want to to build
something higher you can stick objects
at the same time next to each other and
call it an array and you can stick
objects of different types together and
you can call it a structure a class and
yeah in C++ a class an astrologist it's
roughly the same and if you want to have
something that has parts in different
parts of the memory you can point to
them with a pointer that's that's an
address that's it it's very very simple
it's it's about the simplest thing you
you see I assume everybody here can
understand this you take a bunch of
students right out of an undergraduate
course and they can find this
complicated because it have all the
things to hiding the machine that
they're used to okay but this is this is
important there's only a snag here
that's not why machine look like
machines are much more complicated than
that you know they all were when Dennis
came up with this so this is an
abstraction of the machine this is
something that allows us to think about
the machine it's something that allows
compilers that you know write code for
that model it's something allows
optimizers to generate good code from it
and if we have to explicitly deal with
all of these things things get
complicated
hate it so we want to hide as much of it
as possible and the C++ machine model
therefore is an abstraction itself and
as a matter of fact its abstractions all
the way down because your hardware's an
abstraction to mean an ADA x86 does not
execute 886 instructions there's a layer
of silicon the translate 886
instructions into something that's
better to execute for those of you who
old enough MIPS machines is what it's
like and that that way you can do
dynamic scheduling and all the other
good stuff so it's abstractions all the
way down and we have to find the
abstractions are suitable for what we
are doing on the machine we are doing it
on so way I look at abstraction is that
I would like abstraction but I would
like abstraction I can afford and
especially when we are close to the
hardware you you really don't want
abstractions that adds helpful things to
your data structures there are languages
that can tell you for a given object
what type it is and what the time was
when it was created that just mean every
object has to have two more words you
have languages where every object has to
live in the FreeStore so it has to have
a free store header over there and you
have to indirect to get it as far as I
can count that's just three words wasted
sometimes that's wonderful it helps but
sometimes it isn't so what I don't want
any room below C++ except possibly
assembler I I wrote that somewhere in
the 80s and we're repeating it ever
since and it's maybe not even that I
think sometimes we can beat human
written a simpler without too much
trouble I'm going to go there not if for
everything not for machines that has
instructions that we don't have etc
that's inline assembly what you don't
use you don't pay for no distributors
fat and what you do use a language
feature you shouldn't be able to hand
code
any faster and Sarah or head obviously
does not mean zero cost you always pay
for what you use if you want an
indirection you pay for going through
that indirection if you want some extra
data associated in your object you have
to pay for the bytes in it
okay I say that because I've been
actually repeatedly attacked for for
having overhead yeah of course I asked
on the virtual function you get an
indirection that's what it's for
if you don't want the indirection have a
virtual function and so know what you
ask for
there is no magic so a lot to do with
software development has to do with
tools but I have about 60 minutes and
you can go to the rest of the conference
here and you can get something of the
tools I just listed there I'm just not
going to there I'm going to focus on on
language issues so different kind of
systems to require different styles of
usage I've had lots of confused
discussions I remember one case talking
to a guy at a conference and everything
he said made no sense to me and nothing
I said seems to get through to him and I
couldn't understand what on earth is
going on I mean I'm not usually that
wrong and neither are the people I
talked to say okay let's back off here
what are you programming oh I thought I
told you fuel injectors they do listen
to squirt every every through my
milliseconds anyway so I thought it was
one of these big things to the screen
and that's why nothing said though said
made sense on both sides so you have to
know what you are talking about for big
systems I recommend to full C++ it's
whatever you want from the language you
can afford if you have a big system big
systems with real time constraints use
the full language except for the
critical path I mean if I'm doing also a
low latency
code the first no Melek you're just
before that if you if you're counting in
the seconds with something I sometimes
do in my day job and you use a
predictable subset there that's that's
fine your hand you must be caught into
the situation of putting the constraints
of the hardest thing we do into
everything we do because the critical
path tend to be maybe 1% 5% 10% of the
code and we could destroy our
productivity for the rest of the code
for for 95% of what we are doing we
could have our productivity by saying
really we need to hand craft every
allocation and we have to not use
anything that's possibly expensive as if
we were on the critical path we actually
have to separate what we're doing
separate the way we are thinking about
our code from the critical bits that
we're performance and compact does
matter to the rest and small critical
systems you just write the the
predictable subset of C++ all the time
which is basically avoid FreeStore and
usually avoid exceptions and the smaller
safety critical systems but apart the
rest of the language is pretty
predictable if you don't have more than
4 bits in a word probably C++ is not the
answer for you and if you have 8-bit
controllers yeah it can be done but it's
a it's it's a very small subset and
basically in most cases I worry about
space because space is time if I have to
traverse a lot of data to get the answer
it's going to be slow if I can be
compact yeah I can be faster so I I'm
always worrying about the amount of
restore so I'm going to do two sort of
almost case studies first I'm going to
look at things where compactness matters
little gadgets mostly and then I'm going
to go and talk about when we can have
the
full-system full language for Falacci
things it roughly corresponds to Nia
that low-level way hardware performance
use of hardware really matters versus
where you can use your full abstraction
mechanisms so let's look at where
compactness matters I I hear reasonably
often and probably not in this room
given your hands up that C++ is
inherently slower than C I actually
think on average it is faster than C and
we'll get there but let's look at a
simple example we have the smallest
class I could think of it has a
constructor that does a check and stores
a value and it has an operation that
does something in this case it squares
the value and we can do that in c++ blue
and in C that's you have a struct
instead and you have to access functions
now of course there of course both C++
so it's a matter of style but the C
proponents will go for the low level so
let's look what the difference is there
is a use of the struct and there is a
use of the of the class and I was very
pleased to know that the compiler
figured out it was exactly the same code
it's just the surface change if you
prefer if you prefer the top version and
if you prefer the bottom version you you
get exactly the same assembly code I'm
using compiler Explorer here so just to
show the assembly code it's not actually
matter too much what the assembler code
is but it's about the best you can do
in anyway but the fact that it's the
same is I think the interesting bit and
now I made a difference and they're now
slightly different and now you can see
the the code is different that the C++
verse style is has an eight where the
the the c-style has a seven and you look
it's identical cold with one constant
changed so yeah fine you can and remove
those inline functions I cheated I
inline the C functions so that the
compiler would generate good code if I
had forgotten that in a separately
compiled program in many cases this plus
version would have won hands down
because there would have been function
caught in the C code
but I was being fair I put in line on
giving the hint so the compiler should
try harder and so there's no difference
between the hand coded version using the
struck directly and using the functions
for accessing it in either C++ style or
in C style and again it's just figured
out it was the same and let's let's go
to simply there are people who avoid
templates because they're supposedly
expensive and complicated but what I've
done there instead of having the class X
I have X of T where the member is of T
which is a parameter and then I try that
I try with and use it instead off the X
that I had in the previous slide see
this it is with XFX and there it is with
FX X which is a template version and
again it figured out it was set the same
code and just did a jump to what I just
done before if that nipping the template
aversion of course you would have gotten
the code that you got for FX identically
let's try a bit more let's try doubles
doubles are not the same as its so
therefore it has to generate different
code and the floating point is a little
bit more complicated and integers but as
far as I could see for this machine for
this code generator this is not code it
is exactly the same code as you would
have gotten if your hand written that X
is
like XD with that with a double in there
nothing glow there so basically serie or
warhead has met its you may be able to
write better on hand code but in any
large amount of code you couldn't so try
it for yourself
so what i do when i want to know whether
a feature is affordable for my use in
constrained environments i just type it
in to to the to compile i explore and
see what happens it does not do every
machine there is but it does do eighty
sixes and arms and it does linux windows
things like that so you can get a good
idea of what a feature cost and by the
way though I don't think anybody here
would make the mistake of a running code
without having right turn the optimizer
on but I actually get in discussions
with people that genuinely talk about
efficiency and forgotten to turn the
optimizer on and want to write fancier
code to run faster that's pretty and you
have to know your tool chain for this
kind of thing if you really really don't
want to compute things you can compute
at compare at runtime you can compute
them at compile time and there's some
really nice aspects do that like you
don't have to have error handling
because the errors turned out to be
compile time errors rather than calling
an error handler and figuring out what
to do you can't have a race condition on
a constant if you have concurrency in
your system as most of us do most of the
time days having calculate things at
compile time so that you can't have a
race condition is good most of the time
looking up the answer that has been pre
computed as faster than computing it the
exception being if you've been so
fanatical that there is just so many
different places that the access is
expensive okay timidly
more object code so we we can do things
like this example I have here integer
script was requested by somebody in the
Japanese embedded systems industry they
they wanted an integer square root and
so I did one and I use this in example
for constant evaluation so basically
their constant expression s1 is the
square root into the square root of nine
even I could do that in the head it's
three but one two three four what would
I do
I would calculate it and I calculate on
a doodle pad or something and then
outside the result in the problem with
the doodle pad or calculator on the side
is one there's a human involved so
there's a larger chance of error
furthermore once you're taking the
constant and moved it into the code only
the constant is there if something
changes in the for for what you
calculate so I'm some thing you are
dependent on like the size of a word or
something like that now the program is
broken when it gets recompiled with the
changed assumptions you have to have a
magic constant so I like to calculate it
like that and the the load thing down
here with weekdays is an example it
shows we can abstract from the simple
things like integers and actually use
fairly powerful C++ abstraction
mechanisms at zero cost so I want to
know the weekday of October 19 2007
printed out fine the interesting thing
here is I can do a static assert let the
compiler check that the weekday of
October 19 2007 teen is a Thursday it'll
do that at compile time and if I guessed
wrong about the day the program will not
compile this is a non-trivial library
this is by the way it's going to be the
2000 C++ 20 date library that care it's
and time zones and other good things and
it's blindingly fast by the way as you
can guess by the fact that we could
actually do
simple things if the [ __ ] if we're only
dealing with constants we can do it at
compile time if we're using the balls
about days and such then it has to be
done at at runtime but this is fast and
simple enough to use for this kind of
stuff so we don't have to just deal with
with intz we can do more complicated
things the other thing we do at compile
time a lot is we select names like I'm
choosing a library there so I can switch
from one library to another I'm
providing simplified names there the
storage is a vector of T that's the
storage I use for T's and down here we
are composing things a policies and
executor and a locator so that I can say
I want the policy that's sequential and
using the default a locator imagine
you're doing a multi-threaded system
that would be something like that
so a lot of this stuff is done in the
type system at compile time to make sure
we have a symbol notation and a without
extra overhead two extra calls I mean
just because you have something that's
usually defined doesn't mean you have to
pay for it the compiler can absorb a lot
of that stuff here's an example of a
traditional example here I want a handle
and if if I can put the things it's a
handle - on the stack if it's small
enough I use the unstack way of
allocating it otherwise they use on heap
I can compute that small objects goes on
the stack big obstacles on the heap that
that in some cases is a very useful
technique the thing below there is is
using something called enable if in C++
in 11 and beyond it says if the if G is
printable you give it an operator give
the collection the operator
put so you can conditionally add
functions to a shoot to a class which
can be quite useful to get absolute
minimal footprint of your code that is
about the ugliest syntax I ever saw no
it's it's it's very ugly I've seen much
worse and but it does the thing that is
useful of giving properties to two types
if and only if they can actually
implement them I'm not going to explain
the details of this you can look it up
there's quite a few books that'll do it
there are courses at this conference
that will explain to you how to read
that one so I'm not going to go there
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
talk a little bit about how right at
driver the traditional way of writing a
driver and C++ is you have an interface
with some virtual functions so you
interact through the driver to get the
right operation and so you can have
driver one driver too and the user can
can use the appropriate driver without
knowing what it is basically gets double
indirection you go through the driver
driver goes to the virtual function
table of the driver object which gets
you to the right right operation there
so if you have say 15 50 electro motors
in a in in some gadget maybe one of the
flying ones and they use different
different concrete drivers but you can
write your code to says just just
manipulate the the electro motor through
the probe way interface things like that
that's that's usually good enough but
what if it's not good enough what what
if this double indirection is killing
your response time or what is if the
allocations that you go with this
object-oriented style is
painful in your system what can you do
instead so let's just look whoops let's
see how to write a driver and I'll write
another driver and then I'll say that
for character devices I will use driver
one and by the way those drivers take
the device register as a template
parameter and the block device where I'm
using packets I use the packet and I'm
using a different different device
register for that really building in
exactly what I'm doing
there's no polymorphism here no in
directions I'm simply saying characters
are right out using driver one on device
right with the device register
hexadecimal 18 fine so let's have a look
I'm now going to do something I am using
a data structure sorry yes a span which
is basically a pointer and a range which
is a really good way of passing things
around and it's also really good for for
simplifying code it's really good for
range checking if that's what you're
doing but basically you can you can you
can pass data as a pointer and and the
size so I'm having a span of packets
sort of in packets for some in and the
span of characters in characters and I
write the one output the block device
and one out for the character device now
the problem is that yes this is simple
but I have no which kind of device I'm
using all the time why can't it just
picked the right one which is what the
polymorphism is for what the standard
interfaces is forward we use virtual
functions for but you know if I really
know what I want a compile time I don't
need those in directions so what I can
do here is say I'm writing a writer
which take a span of cheese whatever she
is and if she happens to be a character
if constant expression
is same character and so that that is a
notation for saying at compile time
check whether it's a character that sees
a character then use the character
device driver and with the block device
we use the other one and you can see the
the code down there is exactly the same
as the code as if I'd handwritten the
chords to the specific driver so there
you have polymorphism without directions
and it's basically optimal and if you
don't like the function calls through
the two drivers you can inline them
sometimes that makes sense if it's a
symbol driver it makes sense if it's a
big complicated driver it's a dumb idea
but you can know that you can look at it
is it's really straightforward in terms
of you are writing something and the
assembler the machine code looks just
right so basically if you want to
program that way you have to know what
you're doing but you end up using
classes templates some aliasing quite
often Atomics and lambdas is a is common
this kind of code arrays and spans are
common they are arrays a container that
doesn't use any interactions as span is
a way of referring to a set of elements
with without any allocation without any
way and be careful I worry about
interactions a lot that has to do with
the fact that a lot of what I'm doing
has has serious cash effects involved
indirect function calls in particular
dangerous that was why I eliminated them
here that was that by the way was a real
example from a real
gadgets that's deployed in the field not
from a big computer and class
hierarchies and virtual functions be
sure you need them before you use them
because is the cost involved in them and
they bias you towards writing in a
certain style of code which usually
involves more in directions and more
locations and free stall allocation and
de-allocation usually I don't do that
go to pores or stack allocators or
something like that
that's much more predictable okay so
let's let's look at some more ordinary
code that is assumed you can use the
whole language assume you are not really
squeezed for time and and memory that
you can be happy being twice or 50 times
faster than the competition but you are
not actually worried about the last
nanosecond so let's let's do that that's
another embedded gadget for my
definition of a gadget it runs I think
about 25 UNIX systems but if it gets it
wrong things go boom in very interesting
ways because what it does is the drill
into rocks and then stick in explosives
a reliability is a very important thing
basically yes I've said that so
basically I would like to have type rich
code I I find that when code gets win
there's more and more code you need
abstractions you can deal with integers
and pointers and such at a low level but
you can't read it when you get much more
code when it gets into the ten thousand
hundred thousand lines of code you you
need better abstractions it just handles
complexity better and this shows a
difference between two kinds of
programmers which I have labeled C and
C++ and I have noticed that people with
sort of the C attitude says okay let
this thing compile and now can start the
real work which is debugging I hate diba
it's what oil burns - and that that's
not good the the default class way is
basically a compile as your best friend
express your ideas in such a way that
the compiler can tell you when you screw
up because you do we do okay
so different attitudes so we want to
structure the code in such a way that
it's more comprehensible more easy to
check by the compiler and that handles
complexity scale better maybe the old
way will will will work when there's a
thousand lines of code it does not work
with a hundred thousand lines of code
more opportunities for portability
better optimization you can do compile
time code as I showed you and one of the
main things here we do is resource
management a resource is anything that
you have to acquire and then give back
and as we all know giving back is harder
to get right and so to take so we will
look that to be sit in particular and
large code I assume that if you have to
give something back you're going to
forget it some of the times at least I
do so that's and so a resource should
have an owner usually a handle so the
general model is here's something to
represent ownership and that's the own
thing over there and we should make the
acquisition explicit and the release
implicit that's the the name of the game
here's the classical example give me a
fire you said is it very timber only and
that unknown source of bugs the problem
being that you have but too close and
you have a return statement or a long
jump and see or an exception in C++ and
that use F you never get to the if close
and you have a bug we need to do better
the problem is that that just
manipulates pointers and you don't know
what the point well if you're the author
you may know what those pointers mean
you may know that something comes out of
F open must go back
into if closed the documentation say so
but you didn't read it neither did the
compiler so it can't help you and so we
do something like this we create a
handle explicitly the type handle and it
says you open the file if you can't open
it throws an exception you can have
several ways of opening a file and the
important thing is the destructor there
it closes the file so we can now write
the code simpler just give me a handler
to the file called s with read
permissions and however you get out of
that block you you get you you you get
the file closed and that's that simple
and safe and it's it's pervasive in the
in the C++ standard library has been for
for 20 years and so and there are still
people who don't want to use it because
they say usually that exceptions are
evil or something like that I don't
think they're evil we need error codes
and exceptions if a failure to do
something is normal and expected ok let
me check it ok get an error code and if
you meet yet core I can be expected to
handle the problem that that's fine
that's what error codes are for but we
have a lot of cases where errors are
really rare and therefore likely to be
forgotten
so for those of you who use printf when
did you last check the return value of
printf because sometimes it fails it
take live your system is running and
with a network file system or something
like that or you're writing through a
socket the write can fail and if your F
print wasn't checked you have a bug
latent bug in your code so I only
dislike having to remember to check
error codes because I forget and the
more unlikely the error is the more
likely I am to forget and the harder it
is to find the bug because I didn't
think about it era propagated up to an
ultimate caller quite often in a system
that is a play parrots are handled quite
often it's quite near the top of the
system if anything goes wrong get me up
here clean up any messes if I can
otherwise write out some log information
and then you can either bum out and try
and reboot something like that that's
quite common but if you have to put
percolate your error through 15 function
calls then you have 50 cases where you
get an error indicator plus a value you
have to check the error indicator and
then use the value you do this 50 times
the answer is no you don't do it 50
times you forget so you do it 48 times
and now the propagation broken so I
worry about that no suitable return path
I mean if I do a plus B where's a return
path for the air handler da da da I have
many things so basically I I think we
have to choose and big systems we have
the nuisance of having to decide whether
an error is an error or some exceptional
condition and how do we do that some
guidelines for that but here is my
saying if it has to do with overhead and
be able to remember and forget things
there's an implementation overhead for
exceptions with a normal and normal
implementation if and only if the
exception actually happens that is most
if most of the times there is no
exception
nothing happens it's fast if and if an
exception never happens
which should for most programs be in
mode for most exceptions you actually
don't have any cost if you have virtual
memory the whole mechanism can be
sitting out in the virtual memory this
makes it very costly to do your first
exception it has to then go and grab all
the mechanism that you hadn't been using
before so don't use this for hard real
time but look if you can
for a millisecond you can properly
afford even the most expensive exception
and most of the time they don't happen
and after you have done the initial
initialization it actually will happen
so there's a simple experiment that I've
done repeatedly and other people have
done go in levels deep in a chord
sequence and then report an error and
you can do that with exceptions you can
do that with error codes and so which is
a more expensive it's it's it's really
if you do that experiment a couple of
times and you will find that sometimes
error handling is is with error codes
it's really much faster and simpler I
mean Sony and level is one error codes
tend to win big factors not just a
little percents if you go down a course
and the error handling happens the the
error happens infrequently like 100
exceptions when hands down for
performance and Stan leave things so how
rare must an arrow beads would be
considered exceptional that's actually a
question I tend to ask myself a lot and
it depends on a lot of things C++
exceptions were designed the shoe may
announce of that exercise were about 100
that is if if you if an error happens
more than 100 times you core down there
it's not optional you better deal with
it specifically this is not where you
just say oh something happened whoop
somebody deals with it which is what the
accept thing does and and it works
rather nicely and it takes care of the
cases where you go or networking things
like that okay so when you use
exceptions try not to have try-catch in
your code that belongs in
implementations
and just at the top level if every level
test the try-catch for whether there was
an exception in the function you chord
you should have used error codes if you
really want explicit checks all over the
place
error codes is just the same as try
catch try catch it you can use that as a
very slow ugly way of writing
if-then-else don't it's it just drives
you nuts
this is not Java you do not have to have
a try on everything where an exception
can propagate and so just show an exam
example here is a mutex as a matter of
fact there are two mutexes that are
standard and there's one I designed
myself and I can do access like that
scope block da-da-da-dah access data
implicit core that doesn't have any
exceptions in it but it's still our AII
it is a general idea that you initialize
something and it's implicitly released
so you can't say that you don't use our
AII because you're not using exceptions
you can use that the general style of
initializing and owner use the stuff and
implicit in release even if you don't
use exceptions that scoped lock that's a
C++ 17 feature and that is the way you
acquire three mutexes without danger of
deadlock because you do will not proceed
beyond that point unless you have all
three so it's obviously implemented to
try the one try the other if you could
couldn't get the third back off again
and that kind of technique there any
kind of stuff bumbum if you really can't
use exceptions my main example is flight
controls because you can never afford
the the unpredictable exceptions if we
had tools that could measure
the maximum propagation time we could
use it but I haven't been in that
situation so you can introduce a notion
of a valid object and so where you would
have thrown an exception before you you
don't set the valid bit and so you can
write for all of your code open the file
handle or check it was valid now it's
not as pretty as as throwing an
exception and you still have the problem
what on earth do you do if the file
handle wasn't handle wasn't valid you
can do something for a file handle but
if you have to do it with all of your
resources for whenever you use acquire
some memory say it becomes a real pain
to have all of those error hands and
code there but you sometimes have to do
it so basically for ordinary code you
can use most C++ features the STL
containers come in really handy
I always start with a vector and don't
use anything else as I have a good
reason to the good reason may be that
I'm doing lookups so I need a hash table
that's called an unordered map but
basically start with those containers
unless they are unless they don't work
the unless there's a problem with that
you don't need to go any further it's a
good start
and then you can optimize exceptions or
find Crono for time and now if you need
time zones use use date it has just been
voted into the standard you can download
it from the github for it
the name is Howard Hinnant it was a
really good guy and if you can remember
that name you can look it up and github
and find what is going to be put into
the standard actually it was voted in so
it will comments when she exceptions are
find lambdas I haven't gone into lambdas
today they're really useful for things
you do code you execute only once sorry
you only call once and four
parameterizing things to make your exit
your applications more flexible also to
stop repeating the range for is
is really useful for for for writing
simple loops and most loops are simple
for all X in V do something 2 X that's
simplification it actually matters when
you're looking at the code it's easier
to read you don't have to worry
somebody's messing with the loop
variable something like that
it's likely less error-prone and if you
if you have to do anything that's really
critical you have to look at the things
that are not predictable in the sense
that you can guarantee they run enough
enough in a fixed constant time usually
slow usually short fixed constant time
new or malloc throw run time type
identification STL containers used new
when you grow them so either you have to
be careful to set them up before you you
start the engine you can't have new and
delete in in a program that's supposedly
last forever because you can get
fragmentation so you need something like
pools avoid STD function it may contain
a malloc so basically the the first rule
of thumb is for really critical code
don't anything that does a malloc if you
have a malloc you need to delete Sariah
free if you need a free you're going to
get it wrong with a high probability
furthermore it costs something and if
you get fragmentation you you may not
last forever
ok keep simple thing for my opinion
simple means symbol in quality code it
does not mean the lowest level facility
it's fairly easy to tell people to use a
a macro and avoid star and an inch the
problem is there's also very easy to
make bugs at that level cannot be caught
by any analyze or compiler so so you
want to get up with that and so symbol
does not mean low level
I mean symbol in real use and you can do
anything with low-level features and
that exactly the problem I mean why
don't we use go to the answer is it can
do innit
we want something that's better behaved
like a for loop or an if-statement
thing like that or an algorithm at next
level so that's it and build on the
sound foundation that is work a lot to
make sure that the foundation is solid
that your abstractions are solid that
the libraries you use are appropriate
for your task I don't spend all your
time on the world statues and fancy
canons up on the high decks because you
may get trouble
I am act using this picture to scare the
Standards Committee from putting too
many fancy features on instead of
working on the foundations but that
that's that's that's a good story that
one I am about to run out of time I'm
good ok so then I'm going to tell you a
little bit about how what we're trying
to address here the standards what you
can do and what it means like this is
undefined behavior the standard will
tell you all of that it doesn't tell you
what is good code and the language is
big and complicated and you need
guidance I need guidance and so we are
trying to attack the problem of in terms
of what would you like your code to look
like in five years like just like today
is not a good answer it's not good
enough we can do much better than what
we are today
we're very proud of our code today often
but we know we can do better in five
years we know if you could use all the
facilities of the language if we know if
we use them better what would we like to
do and we are tagging the problem in
terms of a cocktail of problems language
design coding rules it says what is good
libraries for easier writing code and
static analysis for enforcement so the
basic idea is the way the the
the doctors kill or kill kill is
illnesses sometimes one medicine isn't
sufficient but a cocktail of them will
work will kill whatever it was that
ailed you and so we're trying to do that
combination there the the targets are
type safety and resource safety problems
we want to eliminate those we want to go
after known complicated techniques you
look to the web and there are no
shortage of people showing how clever
they are and that leads to complicated
code and complicated techniques we would
like to point out when this is gonna
walk board I mean the way I optimize
code these days is first I throw away
all the clever stuff that's usually the
complicated stuff it's the one with all
these fancy pointers going left right
and center and clever uses of multi-core
things like that get rid of all of that
and see if it's good enough now if not
we start building the clever stuff back
again but in in a reasonably good way so
we go after all complicated techniques
known bug sources bugs hide in
complicated code bugs correlate with
certain uses of code so we try for that
and known inefficiencies and so this is
the core guidelines it's a joint project
between quite a few people it's open
source the the main players is Morgan
Stanley Microsoft Red Hat Facebook and
there's a lot of people adding in this
is a very interesting group I mean
Facebook Red Hat and Microsoft in the
same meeting the joint project this is
good there's progress and what we're
after is what I showed on the previous
slide but in particular I want to get
type and resource safe C++ absolutely no
violations of the type system no violate
no leaks of it no leaks no memory
corruption no garbage character if you
don't generate any garbage you don't
need a garbage collector no limits on
what you can say
to be C++ and you're very expressive no
performance degradation and I wanted in
C++ because well I don't want to write
another language it takes too much work
and we want the tool enforced and we
can't quite do that the latest I've
heard is that the Microsoft's analyzer
which is part of issues to Joe and
should be separated out as a program you
can run by yourself but they haven't
done yet can catch essentially all
dangling pointers so anything you ever
saw with a pointer pointing to something
that wasn't there should go away at
compile time actually you static
analysis time you were understanding
analyzer whenever you feel like it so
this is being tested on million line
programs and so it you can find it there
on the github it's called C++ core
guidelines and there's a tiny support
library like the span I showed you
earlier that's actually we're trying to
get that into the standard because we
think it's our business to put the GSL
out of business by making what is useful
part of the standard and what turned out
to be not useful which I hope is nothing
to go away
so that's basically it
I'm not too happy about the support for
embedded systems programming like I I've
never written a real program in this
field that didn't need a pool so I write
my own pool of time morale I fish out my
old pool and modified I don't want to do
then I shouldn't have to do that there
should be there are library supports
like pools and Stata a snag alligators
should be standard some flat flat data
structures should be in the instead of
the the chained one why don't we have a
flat map and the answer is that the
standard library was designed by people
who thought free stole allocation was
was cheap and that think structures were
good well with caches and with with with
constraints on on memory and L okay
that's not good enough also the
guidelines are quite weak on on embedded
systems programming we are trying to
deal with that there is a group in the
Standards Committee led by Mike Wong
from Coldplay he used to be at IBM it's
called the study group 14 games and low
latency if you're interested in this
kind of stuff
think about enjoying this one and it
seems less embedded than formally a lot
of financial types have joined for the
low latency so we actually need more
embedded systems programmers to build
this and the purpose of that group is to
come up with a list of things that will
be useful for standardized mostly
library things and and and then guide
the committee in in that area and so
that's that's something that that's
coming up I had hoped to be more
specific about this but I ran out of
time as could be expected so basically
that's what I wanted to say and I hope
we have time for some Q&A thank you five
minutes
any questions
oh yes
oh yeah yes yes you can use priest yeah
repeat the question here I said that you
shouldn't use malloc and free in
critical systems that's right especially
free because if you use both malloc and
free you can get fragmentation but as
you correctly pointed out the rules very
often is during startup you can allocate
memory provided you can prove that you
didn't run over and a runtime check will
do that and so it's it's quite common
that during startup you can do new or
malloc but never delete because
fragmentation is not predictable
is there any way of enforcing the rule
against new and delete and the answer is
in the language no but there are static
analyzers for sale and for free that can
do that no that says justjust if they're
for the way no that will not work
because you need it during startup
furthermore new on deletes can be hidden
very cleverly in other code the place I
mentioned earlier that bit a lot of
people was that inside is TD function
which is the abstraction that can hold
anything executable there lurks a malloc
and so if you just instead of using
pointers to function use STD function
which is much more elegant and say 4x
error you get hit by by Maalox and it's
not that easy but the aesthetic
analyzers that are pretty good at it
thank you